vamos a hablar de dos tipos distintos de
fuentes ideales una es una fuente ideal
de voltaje y la otra es una fuente ideal
de corriente el símbolo de una fuente
ideal de voltaje es así y ponemos aquí
una indicación del voltaje y se llama de
y esta es una fuente ideal de voltaje
constante voltaje constante y ésta puede
venir de una fuente de alimentación o de
una batería si es de una batería tenemos
este otro símbolo también ponemos la
letra b por aquí y la convención de la
polaridad para el símbolo de la batería
es que este extremo el extremo que tiene
la raya larga ese es el lado positivo y
el extremo con la raya pequeña este es
el lado negativo así es que esta es la
convención para el símbolo de la batería
el otro tipo de fuente ideal es la
fuente de corriente que también tiene un
símbolo con un círculo pero en este
ponemos una flecha
en dirección de la corriente el símbolo
de la corriente es una y se puede ver
así o la flecha también puede ir en
sentido contrario y se ve así
estos son los dos símbolos para las
fuentes ideales de corriente constante y
ahora algo que podemos hacer es graficar
estas dos fuentes la fuente de voltaje y
la fuente de corriente las podemos
graficar formando una curva que tiene
coordenadas b en el eje de las equis y
en el eje de la yes y formar así algo
que se llama la curva característica de
corriente y voltaje o también conocida
como la curva y ve cuando tenemos una
fuente de voltaje constante el voltaje
se mantiene constante y es la corriente
la que sube o baja dependiendo de lo que
demande el circuito pero el voltaje se
mantiene constante así es que el voltaje
se mantiene constante
y esta sería su curva y ve ésta es la
gráfica de un voltaje constante donde el
voltaje es igual a alguna constante de
ahora si lo que tenemos es una fuente de
corriente constante entonces la
corriente es la que se mantiene
constante independientemente del voltaje
si tenemos una corriente positiva su
gráfica ibex se vería así y diríamos
algo así como que la corriente y es
igual a la constante y así es que esta
es la curva y p o también podemos decir
que es la gráfica ive de un voltaje
constante y esta otra es la curva y ve
de una corriente constante bueno estas
son las dos formas básicas como le damos
potencia a nuestros circuitos así es que
ya tenemos un juego completo de
elementos con los que podemos construir
circuitos